we're going to do tonight today is talk
a little bit about the history of the
West how we got to where we are and
that'll give us some idea of what the
foundations of market capitalism are
about and foundations of what America is
about and we're going to we're going to
concentrate on the economic structure
and and that political structure that's
consistent with the economic structure
that we've been talking about so far one
of the one of the reasons that the West
grew wealthy and other parts of the
world didn't in fact if you look at
Zimbabwe right now
one out of air one out of every eight
children will die before the age of five
right and so we might want to look and
say okay why is that happening over
there and that's not happening here and
so historically we moved to a spot which
is market capitalism and a system based
on individual liberty in a and limited
government and this is historically what
happened was we extended that what Hiatt
calls that sphere of freedom that
ability to act according to your own
plan which we said was crucial to making
markets work and that is if you look at
a history of the West you see this
gradual expansion of the individuals
ability to act according to their own
plan because we just compared your life
today with what it would be like if this
were 900 AD you'd see that you have a
lot more freedom to do things than you
did when you were a serf in 900 AD
innovation is what makes us wealthy I
like so much since we're not wealthier
today because we have more wheat than
they did in the 13th century or we have
more tapestries but we have lots of
stuff they didn't have in fact about
half of the things that you're going to
use in the next week or so didn't exist
and
18:50 already mentioned that earlier
right so think of how many things exist
today that if this were 1250 would you
really how would you have that today and
probably almost none of it would exist
in 1250 you would never refrigerator.i
wouldn't have strawberries and you know
January you wouldn't have all the things
that we have and so what meat what
really happened in the West is we
created the system of innovation and
that's what makes us wealthy we didn't
get wealthy just because we accumulated
more stuff we got well because we
created new stuff and how did that
happen that happened because we
instituted the idea of property rights
property rights are crucial to a system
of market capitalism and yesterday we
said or right Tuesday Tuesday we said
that it is property rights and the
protection of property rights that are
why we have government in the first
place
government is there and its purpose is
to protect life liberty and property
that's what the role of government is
and that has has developed in the West
as opposed to other places where the
role of the tribal chief is to tell you
what to do we have a centrally planned
system and there are no property rights
we farm things and caught in the Commons
and we hunt things in the Commons and
that is not a very productive way to run
things so